good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i am delighted to welcome you to
this edition of our 2021-2022
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the
college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the national institutes of general
medical sciences
this year's theme is ethical challenges
of artificial intelligence and
biomedicine where we enjoy presentations
on friday afternoons from leading
thinkers about the promise opportunities
and hurdles associated with ai
applications in the biomedical sciences
selected participants in our biomedical
data science innovation lab program have
the opportunity to leverage these
presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person grant project
development workshop to be held here in
historic charlottesville virginia in
june
today i am delighted to welcome our
speaker dr marissa salazar campo from
the university of california irvine
marissa is a graduate of stanford
university usc and holds her phd in
business administration from nyu stern
school of business she is an assistant
professor of organization management
organization and management at the paul
marriage school of business her research
focuses on knowledge integration
learning and innovation in
interdisciplinary teams she is the
founding president of the international
network for the science of team science
as she is the program director of team
science at uc irvine and ucla and a lead
contributor to the team science
acceleration lab at uc irvine in
continuing our
2021-2022 biomedical data science
seminar series theme ritz's lecture
today is entitled team science in big
data science bridging the divide in her
presentation murzu will remind us that
all the complexity of scientific
problems coupled with a growing need for
specialized expertise necessitates the
formation of teams of experts who will
collaborate across disciplinary
boundaries and generate new scientific
breakthroughs the variety of knowledge
available in big data focus team science
provides a breadth of expertise to
tackle these challenges that would be
intract intractable by any single
discipline or any single individual
alone the presentation will demonstrate
the use of formal interventions to
support collaborative uh science across
data and disciplines as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via youtube and if you are
watching on youtube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2020 2021-2022
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are strongly encouraged to
submit any questions for maritza via the
chat feature in their zoom sessions i
will synthesize these and ask those
questions on your behalf during the last
10 minutes or so of the lecture and with
that marissa welcome thank you so much
for doing this we are just delighted to
hear your lecture today
hi everyone good afternoon it's a
pleasure to be here with you all
um i want to give a little bit of
background um with regards to my own
journey and what brings us together here
today
um like like jack mentioned i am a
scholar of organizations and teams and
in understanding what makes a team of
experts into an expert team
i've explored a lot of different worlds
than a corporate boardroom i have been i
have worked with the army research
office i have worked in fortune 500s
with teams but i've spent a good deal of
the last 10 years working with teams in
the biomedical biomedical clinical space
as well as
with machine learning deep science deep
people who use
computer science and machine learning
and so
what i bring to you today is a mixture
of what i might present to a group of
business scholars interested in gaining
effectiveness and efficiencies
while also being sensitive to the
nuances of the ventures of discovery
and jack mentioned a couple of different
spaces where i
you know show my work and contribute to
the intellectual community
and one of them is the international
network for the science of team science
which convenes
scholars and practitioners
who are interested in understanding how
to support
scientific teams
the second is around
uci and ucla i provide ongoing
consultation
to teams who either want to really kick
off
well or who face hurdles along the way
and could use some additional guidance
i particularly want to highlight this
team scholarship acceleration lab which
is sponsored by our vice chancellor for
research
and you know unless i'm ill-informed is
probably the leading site right now on
the web for guidance about team work at
various stages of formation of various
stages of development and i highly
recommend checking out the resources on
that page when you have a chance
so um
throughout the talk i'll be talking
about various aspects of teamwork
leadership
and especially bridging
the tools of machine learning and
computer science and various phenomenon
i want you to really be reflecting on
your own experiences participating in
teams using big data and analytics and
as jack mentioned please feel free to
put your questions up on the chat
if you have questions i'm sure someone
else either here um this morning on the
talk or on youtube is struggling with
some of the same
uh same are the same challenges or have
the same questions that you might
okay so i'm going to start
with a definition of what team science
is
and i say this because across the
national institutes of health the
national science foundation and various
foundations there's an increasing
emphasis on
team science
multiple pi investigative mechanisms or
developing a management plan which means
that we're getting
we're getting to the place where we say
gosh the technical knowledge has got to
be amplified and catalyzed by the ways
we interact together
to answer important questions
and team science um it's the
it's the work that we do collaboratively
to analyze a particular research
question about a particular phenomenon
and it is the case that team science can
occur within a single discipline but
more often than not we're talking about
teaming or collaboration across
um
across various
disciplinary or methodological divides
and so this notion and i have this
picture here of albert einstein of the
lone investigator tinkering away by him
or herself
um in the pursuit of knowledge is in
some ways quite obsolete and i'll
actually present to you some data in
support of this view
but what i will say that
you know i often say with with
scientific discovery that it's so much
about the ways that we and teams
even begin with formulating our problems
and you know he often would say um you
know the question shouldn't be
you know what is five plus five but
rather how many different ways could we
get to ten
and when we're in teams with people who
have very different perspectives we're
more likely to find divergence and
alternative pathways that just might be
our means to the next big big
discovery
so
here here you see some data from um
scholars who were at the time out of
northwestern
where you know they said gosh it seems
like more and more work is happening
collaborating collaboratively
is this in actuality the case and so
this work here spans 1975 to 2005 and so
we can even anticipate that these these
trends are even greater now
but essentially what it what this data
says is that virtually in all fields
research is being done in teams and
you know the exception might be the
humanities and the arts where painting a
portrait writing a novel is still a solo
a solo act
but what we do see is that often when
people are working together in teams
they're producing work that is high
impact
and contributing an important way
more than we see an author working in
you know by themselves in a single
domain
and
with the work that i've been able to do
i've had it's been such a joy honestly a
joy to get to work with scientists who
are not necessarily tethered to
you know what their contributions might
be
in their own field and right rising to
notoriety from narrow contributions but
are truly curious souls interested in
figuring out how we get closer to
solving cancer or reducing
obesity in particular communities
or here in california thinking about how
can we better understand the patterns of
forest fires using again
machine learning
and so in this pursuit
they have said gosh you know to get to
my answer in my
discipline alone i don't see the right
frameworks or i think there are other
other methodologies we could use
and it leads them to cross the silos
that often are pretty
difficult to transcend in our university
systems
all in the hope that they're going to be
able to answer some of these really
complex health or societal problems
and in drawing together the variety of
perspectives different tools um we have
seen uh you know knowledge synthesis and
the creation of of new solutions so all
that to say that there's there's great
promise right and we've even seen at the
you know throughout the last two years
with the covet pandemic where drawing
together um different kinds of scholars
has really led to rapid discovery of
answers or solutions
um that being said um it is not the case
that teaming across disciplines
specialties professions or
um geographic locations is a walk in the
park
and um this data which um is also
you know about a decade old took a sub
sample of 500 ns nsf funded projects and
they said
all of these projects had
great
intentions around
teaming and collaboration and they were
going to involve multiple universities
and various pis
and if you look at this chart it
essentially says well gosh the more
disciplines the more universities the
harder it actually is to produce
knowledge output and those scholars
define knowledge output output as
patents publications or other kinds of
products
and
um
so i on the one hand want to say
you know while teaming
it's the way everything is going
collaborating across disciplines
it might be the means to some of our you
know again to solve some of our most
intractable problems
yet at the same time
when we cross those different chasms
we're going to encounter various
challenges
and those challenges come from the
inherent features of team science itself
and this figure is drawn from the
national academies of science report on
2 200 2015
which um to my knowledge is the most
downloaded um national academies of
science report to date as people are
often trying to figure out how to you
know team better
but we have whenever we work together in
in scientific teams we're often looking
at
fairly large
teams um sometimes we're looking at
teams of teams when we look at research
centers that have
you know multiple teams embedded within
a broader unit
we can have really different goals when
we come together in a team and you know
just to highlight some of my later
takeaways from this talk
we you know i've seen in some of my work
where the
computer scientists on a team compared
to the scholars that they're
collaborating in with other fields have
really different time scales as to when
work is ready to get published and what
contributes
a significant um you know addition to
the field relative to other disciplines
we also have team members coming in and
out of teams right permeable team and
group boundaries
we are linked together by phenomena by
data by our office space right we really
need to
lock sync our interactions within teams
it's not just like hey i did all this
work and let me pass it back over to you
and hands off
we have geographic dispersion and
you know i sometimes show this this
slide where we talk about the difference
between the wright brothers making their
simple flying contraption and the number
i think it's 30 plus experts that are ma
that are necessary just to do the engine
in a 737 at boeing
but in getting more and more schooling
these days we become specialists in
pretty narrow areas and that narrow
specialization makes it even harder for
us to connect to one another
and our expertise
um add on to that that we see
um more more gender parity in science we
see people from different backgrounds
from different cultures
people who you know really just have
this high diversity of membership
and it's no wonder right that we have a
hard time
working in teams effectively
so um some of these challenges again
right as we go into the practical
day-to-day can be that we
you know perhaps we find a couple of
collaborators on our own campuses
where we share a common interest in a
particular problem or
societal challenge or empirical
area
and we want to get to work and we sit
down and
we're trying to coordinate what you know
and what they know and how those pieces
fit together in doing so
we're using really different terminology
we're using we're seeing the phenomenon
from different levels of analysis and we
were trained to do work
that may or may not feel highly
compatible
on top of that we get to administrative
complexities
and that can come in a lot of different
forms where it's well who's the lead on
this project
what percent effort are you
if i want to do a sub award to another
campus
they're just all these different pieces
that can create challenges and conflicts
as we try to figure out the legality if
you will or the administrative aspects
of working together
and then you sit there and you're going
okay i thought this would be really
exciting to go work on this grand
challenge with these new
colleagues and this is taking time this
is
really requiring a lot of effort
when if i were to stay in my discipline
stay with people who use the same tools
publish in the same
outlets i could probably get this work i
get some work done a lot more quickly
right where where that for many of you
on the call you'll start to say gosh
i've got to get this many publications
before
next year to get tenured and you say
forget it i'm not doing this team
teaming collaborative work
until later
so it's no surprise right that often
when we do see collaboration and
interdisciplinary teams it's
you know
scholars that are a little later on in
their career
so you might say to me okay maritza i
understand all these challenges but come
on i've you know i've been on teams
forever and
um we all know we're all part of
different teams we're all doing it so is
it really as tough as you say it is
and i thought i would put this highlight
this research because they're
specifically looking at people that
teams that are
hoping to do work around i.t information
technology and integrate computer
science with other disciplines
and what
this particular paper highlights is that
50
of this sample right 55 pis from 23
institutions
basically write up this beautiful poetic
funding proposal that says we are going
to work together
and we're going to collaborate in this
way and the bio sketches all seem like
they're you know like pieces of a puzzle
and then they get the funding and they
start working and essentially everybody
goes to their four corners of the campus
and does their work until the progress
report is due
9 10 months later
and the pi who's a wonderful writer
weaves together a nice little report but
possibly
but really
these are like
separate independent pieces of work
they're co-acting but not
really working together and i'll explain
what that looks like later
the second set is a little more
coordinated
and they say hey
we we receive the funding and
we are making sure that we're attending
different talks i'm sharing my work with
this other area they're sharing their
findings with the another pi and they're
at least
maybe even maybe they share if this was
about you know working with some other
samples maybe they're sharing a
refrigerator or a common data set
there's something linking them together
that requires
a little more coordinated action around
either again a data set talks
etc
but this
this highest level of integration where
we have scholars coming together jointly
formulating a problem
deciding how they're going to work who's
going to work when
maybe even changing their methodologies
because of feedback and
information they're gaining from another
colleague this ends up only being you
know roughly a third of the sample
that engages in this integrative
cross-disciplinary
work despite everyone saying oh this is
what we're going to do
and so
um you know i have this question that
you know is it really that elusive to
work in this integrated way
and the two studies i just highlighted
say yes it's the outcomes end up you
know our outcome suggests that we
struggle to work across specialty and
discipline
and then in practice we often feel more
comfortable just returning back to our
home base
doing our work separately and perhaps
piecing it together loosely
but
i'm going to guess that every single
person
on this call and on the internet when
you thought about investing this much
time and effort
in an academic career
you hoped to understand you know what
what is black matter or
how can we solve this rare disease or
right you hope to to to pursue
this this endeavor to make a difference
and
for the number of reasons i've just
mentioned it's actually quite hard to
socially and socially interact with our
colleagues in a way
that gets us closer
to
progress
and
um what i want to highlight
right is that
while
you know getting
funded getting a lab is often the
product of having a series of papers and
showing technical astuteness
that's a really different skill
than learning to lead and manage a
science team
and often when i have
different investigators on you know from
around the country really say hey can
you help me out
it's you know sometimes it's a junior
faculty but sometimes it's pretty senior
individuals
um you know vice vice chairs and
chancellor saying
hey this is this is more than i thought
i now have a lab of 10 plus
i'm leading a budget of over a million
maybe
you know
two
and i have
administrative staff that i'm keeping on
full-time
and i am now a manager i'm now creating
workspaces work processes i'm getting
updates and
i didn't go to school for this i went to
school to learn how to i learned
mathematics i learned coding
not this right
and so
some of what you know what what is my
you know why at work and why i do what i
do is to try to say how can i supplement
what is
you know the gift of
intellectual prowess with
the leadership and management skills to
really make sure that science teams and
individual collaborators tap into their
fullest potential and don't and end up
in that 35 percent that is able to truly
integrate and create new knowledge by
piecing together disparate expertise and
tools in some novel way
and so
you know what do i mean when i say
effective team scientists um generally i
believe that this is about learning to
take a project from formation all the
way to completion
and when we have various experts in the
room creating space for all of those
different individuals
to
share how they see the problem what they
see in data
how to
create values like ethics and
transparency that enable people to work
in a synchronous way
is really key
not to mention that
it doesn't take very much for a team to
become factioned and to have us then
dynamics and in particular it's very
easy for
computer scientists and data scientists
to seem like
you know the
uh means to an end right the oh well
we're the scientists doing the work and
they're just running analysis in this
way on the side and really as many of
you on the call no that's not the case
and in fact new insights can come from
the data that can reinform
perhaps the you know the primary
discipline or the content experts so we
want to think about how do we not uh
allow for
there to be any discrepancies and power
and status and who deserves a
quote-unquote seat at the table or
the time in a in a work meeting to share
what they see and to share what they
know
i have this comment here about the ease
of deferring to high status individuals
and groups which can mean
you know senior um senior individuals
maybe men over women perhaps people with
more technical ability rather than
qualitative skills there's so many
different ways that we let
status and hierarchy um
you know rear their
ugly heads and our scientific teams and
ultimately we end up hearing one
dominant voice and again the science
becomes
less multiplex and multifaceted and so
ultimately when i walk in and i
to a team a team being led by an
individual i'm looking to say is this a
person
that is leading in a way where they're
getting participation there's richness
there's a sort of feeling of team flow
around
the work itself
and do people want to stay working for
this particular individual
especially since it's a choice
so uh you know i i had asked jack ahead
of time on campus
or elsewhere i really think that there's
value in seeking out training and
development as it relates to who you are
as a leader and how you could lead more
effectively and i'll highlight one
example of the sorts of trainings that i
provide
and the reason that these workshops are
useful is that you can gain
skills in how you're communicating how
you're leading how you're managing team
processes and even for some of you who
are underneath lead pkis thinking about
well how do i
you know manage from the middle or even
from the bottom in terms of making clear
what your role is on a team how you're
how you're seeing the work um aligning
with your pi's
um you know
six month year plan and making sure that
you're getting what you need from all
the teams that you're a part of and
in scientific teams using big data i
also think figuring out how can we use
different tools
to make sure that others can gain access
into what we know whether it's the way
we're writing or visualizing either data
or the ways we're going to work together
these can be very very important to
unlocking the potential of teams
and these are just some different
examples of the kinds of um either one
on one
in a way coaching that
i've been able to do with teams
and
the research that i've done on various
interventions
so um i wanna i wanna say that you might
be going okay um i see that you do a lot
in various areas but what do you really
know about
data scientists and our work
i just wrapped up um a five five-year
national research training grant at uci
where
we worked with in the end about 60
doctoral students who
were either connect either from the
computer science department doing
machine learning
and they were partnered with individuals
from either earth system science
chemistry physics and a little bit in
biology
and what it meant was that every trainee
that came into our group was essentially
assigned a mentor who was a computer
scientist and a mentor in the other
field
and it meant that there was this new
frame around what does it mean to create
the transdisciplinary scholar who's
working at the interface between this
novel computer science computer um
decoding
uh
tools and then the particular field
context so we move we you know we we're
we're currently writing up some papers
where we're suggesting that we've got to
move away from this notion of the
scholar having a single mentor to them
having a constellation of support
systems that enable them to perform
effectively
um one of the things that was really
useful and training and developing these
scholars
was to create to group them together in
micro
uh communities within their various
cohorts where they were assigned at
least one computer scientist phd and
then individuals from the other
disciplines
with the hope that they would learn some
new statistical or modeling approach and
then we asked them to present what they
learned
to the broader community
so examples of this became we heard
we obviously heard about different
machine learning techniques we also
learned about
novelty and machine learning and
audio and visual
expertise very lots of new approaches
were brought about in this group but
what really mattered i would say is that
the scholars were placed they were
giving they were given data
and exposure to new modeling technique
but as we prepared these scholars to
work with these two mentors
we made sure that they receive training
and communicating across disciplines
thinking about how their teams are
composed managing conflict managing
their mentor and mentee and also
some basics and where you know
tips on knowledge generation or create
you know generating creativity
in their various work teams
and what i what i'm quite proud of is
what we saw um we had an external
evaluator over time and we were able to
see
a pretty significant we already you know
i'll say first of all this is
self-selection
uh any student that chooses to do this
interdisciplinary work already probably
has some sense of efficacy in doing so
that being said we were able to increase
their um their confidence in being able
to
you know
have engage with others in a positive
way interdisciplinary interdisciplinary
way by about seven percent
and then um we really focused a lot on
communication and how they could better
interface with their various mentors and
with students in different different
domains
i want to highlight though
i'm going to go back here i want to
highlight a couple of takeaways though
from watching these um various teams and
so in the end we ended up with i ended
up studying 60 different
triads of computer scientists and
individuals from the uh physical or
chemical sciences
you know the very first is that um
the the students themselves and the the
computer scientists counterparts
really did have to roll up their sleeves
and become content experts and again the
the domains included everything like i
mentioned from forest fires to um
patterns of forest fire basically got
pixel data from nasa to understand
changes in forest fires we looked there
was a lot coming off from linear
accelerators data of boson hicks and
other sorts of complex data sets
and the students could not just from an
armchair say oh well you know show me
that show me the pictures of your data
or show me send me the output and i'll
run some some some algorithms on them
just wasn't the case and i think we're
all seeing now it's no longer you know
2010 where we can generally get a
phenomenon and try to apply
machine learning approaches
i think it is the case now that one has
to become really steeped in the context
or in the phenomena that they're
interested in
because the cost can be a risk of
underestimation and quite often
as students would spend a lot of time in
a chemistry lab
looking at certain reactions and seeing
the output in the computer data and then
needing to code it would be like oh gosh
i didn't understand that there was this
assumption or that assumption that i
didn't i didn't build into my model
um
and um and then communicating
sufficiently
what was happening with
the you know the programming
to the person who was in the other
discipline
i i just can't estimate i just can't um
you know overemphasize enough
the value that comes in learning how to
simply
convey
how a model was built
what approaches what what
estimations were underlying a model
etc etc in a way that individuals from
the other discipline could really
capture and then on the other hand
making sure that the individuals who
were
you know content or context experts also
gave enough
of an understanding of the trends and
the nuances and the long-term shifts in
what they were looking at to allow the
computer scientists
to have an adequate picture of what the
work might be
and and i i wish i could say it was a
meeting or two but it's not right it's
hours and hours of sitting in
another person's work domain to really
understand uh what it is that they're
they're looking at
and i will say i
you know i don't have a crystal ball or
anything but i i would say that the
students who
you know maybe there might be one or two
content domains that a computer
scientist over the course of their
career to really understand quite well
whether it's some some biological
phenomenon or
uh there's there's just too much of a
risk of not truly understanding what you
are trying to represent with data and
again i know jack was very interested in
ethics but perhaps misrepresenting the
phenomenon because you're just not
sophisticated enough in your
understanding of that phenomenon
and so putting in that time and effort
as early as in the graduate school years
to get familiar with other phenomena i
think is quite quite important to do
ethically sound
modeling
uh so i'm going to highlight a little
bit about
some recent work that i'm
hoping to submit here in the next couple
weeks
where um
you know what you say well
you know i'm just very interested and
saying how can we help scientific teams
produce more and be more effective
and there's a bit of a bias in the
research and that when we see the
successes of scientific teams
collaborative science teams
there's bias in that they survived and
they made it through the rough patches
and were able to celebrate their wins
and i do know
you know qualitatively the number of
times i see
investigators come together across
campus have a couple of meetings
and then nothing ever really comes of
those first initial
points of convening and i wonder well
is there anything that could be done to
help in those formative stages of
development
to enable scholars to connect and
interlink their knowledge in a way where
they can see oh this is what we could
really do together in a little um you
know fast track it in a way
and
often um
you know we in in traditional management
research we
have a task right we need to market this
particular product
marketing requires you know people that
know a b c and d let's make sure we
staff the team and get to work
the thing about
scientific exploration is there's often
a lot of uncertainty about what we're
looking at
it's changing all the time
and as a consequence the solution and
who we need to be on the team is also
always changing and i have these images
of the covid um
of kovid right because
it represents a biological system that
one day we understand it one way and the
next day it's transforming and we're
having to update our models update the
ways we see the problem in order to
again find an updated solution
but regardless when we're thinking about
putting some structure to team training
when teams are coming together around
problems that have no clear endpoint
to me this is a conundrum where i say
well gosh it's no wonder that so many
science teams never really launch
effectively
so i wanted to see
where i could i started to sort of look
around for what might be useful in
understanding this problem
and i turned to
some of the work on entrepreneurial
startups or groups and then a little bit
to the literature and corporate strategy
development
and in both of these literatures you
think about um you know how do people
bring brand new
products to a market a market that might
not even exist yet because they're about
to create it
or how do companies define strategy when
their environments are always shifting
when competitors are moving
pandemics are happening right how does
one plan when
there's so many moving parts
and a lot of what this literature
suggests is that
you know suggesting that a plan is
bulletproof solid laid out that the
steps from start to finish are very
clear
is just not practical
and rather what comes up in a lot of
these different spaces is this notion of
piecing together a provisional a
provisional plan an initial scaffolding
for
hey maybe this is something we could do
and then
offering up some
opportunities to probe or test or or
essentially you know hypothesize and say
well maybe if we try this the you know
the customers will like this or perhaps
if we move in the strategic direction
just in one regional site we can see the
effect and maybe consider and possibly
consider that for the company um
you know all around the company
so
what my colleagues and i did is we
basically built a
it's about an hour and a half um
exercise that we took teams that had
just received some seed funding to come
together
after a you know half a page uh intent
to work together
and thought well what if we
bring in you know an external
facilitator to help
build this provisional plan
and and you know for better for worse
we do know that
teams don't often auto correct and
they will you know you guys have all
been in these situations where one
person talks for the you know the whole
meeting or um you sit there and you go
gosh i didn't really hear what everybody
around the room knows i only heard two
or three people talk
and you go to several meetings in a row
and you really just don't know where the
team is going so we thought well perhaps
we can create some
structure
and help
teams
identify a
potential
potential aim
and maybe a couple prototype a couple of
exploratory activities or studies that
they could do
to get them on the right track
and in doing so um perhaps do better
than
teams who do not receive this external
support
to
to develop in the early stages
and i think there's a lot of room for
this right if we think about the number
of hackathons and boot camps and
you know maybe even
start-up ventures i think there's a lot
of room for thinking about what can we
do to support
formation of a team in these very very
very nascent stages and so what we
propose here is that those teams that
receive what we call this provisional
planning or scaffolding intervention are
going to be better at knowledge inter
integration
we have a scale for it and we look at
you know their ability to create some
outputs but beyond that we say gosh even
in creating this
hour and a half not very long exercise
we're going to get we're going to see
more efficiencies
where individuals in the room are going
to have a better understanding
of what other people in the room know
they're going to
have a faster crystallization of what
they're capable of as a set of
prospective investigators
and third when they think about the work
they may want to do
they might actually piece together oh
you can do this with you you can gain
these samples or you have this imaging
and i have this
you know deep learning approach that i
can apply right and the group will start
to see
their
potential
and in that make it over the hump of
being that you know again team that
meets a couple times and never takes off
to actually crossing that first hurdle
to saying you know what
this deserves a spot in my week i think
this team is worth it and the promise of
what we could do together could be
worthwhile let's see where this team
goes
so
we took teams from around the country
who were given
pretty small
seed award from their clinical and
translational science institutes or
awards
and
most of these teams were looking at some
sort of biological cause of disease and
we ended up with about 26 different
teams that were randomly assigned either
to receive this external support or not
and they worked together for six to 12
months hoping to submit another proposal
hoping to get some work accomplished and
you know here's a sort of we did a
baseline then we did the intervention we
followed up and then we wanted to see
some of the outcomes of these teams
now here's an image from
one team actually this is in virginia
this particular not at not at your
institution but another in virginia and
uh we
ask in this exercise that they put the
aims down they think about who needs to
be doing um what work on the team what
it takes to
um essentially
put together a beginning plan of what
everyone could do over time what
resources are available on campus for
them to use again through a series of
nine
nine steps in the hour and a half
we measured again knowledge integration
we had a couple of different questions
things like
by combining what everyone knows on this
team did your team come up with a
solution that differs differs from the
way that things are normally done
or the team demonstrated its originality
and its work due to the combined
contributions of its various members
also we
we asked them for their traditional
measures of scientific productivity
right things like
their publications their funding and
their subsequent grant submissions
we measure those intermediate factors
that again the psychologists like myself
are very interested in um here are some
of the
mean standard deviations and
and i you know i
i understand too the low
sample size relative to some of you in
data science um it's probably appalling
but i'm hoping you'll bear with me to
see the gist here
which is that we did find that the teams
who receive this intervention they end
up
more productive and they end up
integrating knowledge integrating
knowledge more
and sure enough they learned more about
who knew what in the team and they
gained a better sense of confidence in
what the team could do together
but those two factors did not lead to
the outcomes the only driver that was
explained the relationship between our
intervention and improved knowledge
outcomes and knowledge integration
was a better understanding of how
everyone's expertise fits together
to accomplish the aim of the group
and here's some of that output data that
i was sharing with you
we see higher knowledge integration and
the scaffold intervention
we see they're
similar for how much internal money they
go on to ask for from their campuses
take a look at their external grant
submissions almost
every single team in our intervention
ended up being ready to submit a grant
in six to 12 months
faster than the other group which will
probably get there but not quite yet at
the point of collecting our last round
of data we see almost twice as many
publications and we also see a higher
impact factor from having just supported
again the social interactions the
knowledge sharing
processes at the very beginning of
team life
which highlights for me a couple of
important things you know one is that we
you know
we move beyond this notion of you know
connect pieces of puzzles that simply
need to be adjusted
to recognizing that scientific work is
more fluid flexible and adaptable and
this provisional plan
where we literally tell everybody this
is not set in stone let's just talk and
hypothesize and play this is very
functional for scientists to wrap their
minds around or investigators
but we also see that maybe just like we
you know we see in child development
where imprinting ages 0 to 5 has a
particularly strong effect
that perhaps the time the timing of an
intervention for a scientific team early
on is really critical
to setting standards of how we should
interact and and how to collaborate and
sync our knowledge together
uh you know it's definitely a plug for
not assuming a room of scientists who've
all gotten scientific training is well
equipped to manage social interaction
and facilitation
to get to solutions and occasionally
bringing somebody in from the outside to
watch how people are communicating to
see how information is being shared
etc um i will say that um
one key that i will highlight for this
particular audience
is um as we think about coordination in
data science
data sciences i i do think that what i
what i often call a communication
covenant
could probably be
very useful
and especially in combination with some
basic software engineering know-how
things like hey what you know a document
that's like
when did you last touch the code what
code are you using how will we indicate
versions of code
um
you know making sure that there's an
understanding as people are coordinating
and synchronizing around data
so that a you know a supervisor a pi can
go into the data and literally see who's
done what
um i cannot emphasize enough the um
the ground rules for interaction
either technically or socially
it's really like the essentials of
teamwork that you just you know if it's
not happening in your lab and this i
would maybe spend a day in the summer
just covering hey what are my
expectations for
um the ways we interact with the data
and enhance transparency about what
needs to get done um
generally for effective you know kind of
a couple of last points for all the
proposals and works work that you have
ongoing it's really important to always
highlight hey who's going to do what
who's responsible for what
uh how do we link together in a project
you saw in my intervention picture that
there are you could visually see the
projects and who was going to be working
with whom
really useful for everybody to see
the work
identifying how people are gonna
interface across different components um
and then if you're interested we do have
measures for assessing team
team cohesion team integrative capacity
transdisciplinary orientation i'm happy
to share any of those with you
as a leader getting ready to
you know go for your next funding
i want to say to you that you have to
showcase
yes i can do machine learning yes i can
apply my tools in these novel ways
but they're going to want to see more
and more language that suggests that you
have the management skills to bridge to
lead projects to connect
different sites and
data points and institutions around big
data
and i you know have a couple of some
texts in here about ways that people
create this narrative about their soft
skills to assure funders that they're
the right person to take on
the
quite hairy nature of big data meets
complex phenomena together
and if you feel like
you could use a little support there are
individuals like myself where you know
you can and i again i would go to your
ctsa and see but you can say can i put
you on for one percent two percent so
that in my management plan i say yep we
have here's our problem here our bio
sketches here's
um you know how we're going to work
together
but we've also brought on this team
science expert who will be doing our
kickoff who will check in once a month
who will be fine-tuning
um the ways we interact and and connect
with one another it's okay to to see the
limits of your expertise and bring on
others
who can serve as a sort of checks and
balance again catalyzing fast tracking
smoothing out the interpersonal
challenges that come up as we team
around
quite challenging phenomenon
so um i think with that i just have my
last um thank you and if you want to
connect on linkedin
you know feel free i'd love to stay in
touch
thank you so very much you guys you were
talking you had that early example that
you talked about of the
55 p.i and co-pi project and they were
all gonna that all sounded really great
on paper and then they got the grant and
everyone just kind of like it was just
this diaspora of activity and all that
promise for team activities and how
people can work together sort of
i don't know kind of
didn't happen
until the progress report's due and
anyone has to kind of make it up on the
spot which jack you know how it goes
it's like hey send me your paragraphs
you send me your paragraph and i'll
weave it together and make it make it i
don't know what you're talking about
i've never been involved in any kind of
project like that but i think it's
really interesting because and frank on
all honesty i have and i'm sure that
many of the people listening have been
involved with those where it's you know
it's a great idea looks great on paper
and you were able to convince reviewers
and you get the money and then all of a
sudden the team element of it sort of
goes by the wayside
and trying to find ways to kind of
maintain that teaminess is super
important and i think some of the ideas
you shared are super important one thing
i wanted to to ask about is
one which we're doing sort of right now
on zoom is how is team science affected
by
our remoteness now usually you know in
team science it's like if we can all get
together in a conference room and we'll
prepare notes so we could do a post-it
slam and we could do all the things
in zoom land it's a little more
difficult what sort of recommendations
do you have when we're
kind of working in this way moving
forward
so i i appreciate the question because i
think the way we
we collaborate is always going to be
different moving forward um the the
first comment i have is around this
communication covenant that i mentioned
um prior
and i think why that's important is when
we don't have the safety and i mean that
in a catching our inefficiencies of
walking past each other in the hallway
it worked to say how's that project or
where are you on that
uh we end up with a lot of blind spots
and so um where i think it's useful is
to set up a couple of
best practices right so one is
before a zoom meeting making sure that
there is a digital agenda
maybe a google sheet that everyone can
see
maybe assigning someone to be a
note capture of what is shared
because often it's hard to facilitate
and capture everything that's being said
at the same time yeah
having things like a paper progress
spreadsheet where you can literally go
around your lab and say hey where are we
on this where are we on that
and then um
and then i would say and this is
especially for you know graduate
students and junior faculty
i would in if you're not meeting
regularly and it was probably more the
case in the height of the pandemic
but i would get in the habit of
figuring out does your
whoever it is that you're you know
working with the most do they want an
update
uh on paper
where maybe it's an email that says hey
as an update this this week i cleaned
this data i built this model i
met with these two other doctoral you
know graduate students
um but that's a sort of reporting up so
that you know what it is that's going on
um i do think that a lot of the um when
i would do some various consultation
around campus i did feel that there was
less like the social sciences and other
areas where
you the scholars couldn't do their work
because they couldn't physically
interact because of the covid pandemic
they were more negatively impacted than
scholars like yourself jack who the data
they could access it from wherever they
they are
um
but i do think um just again having that
same covenant of hey are you working
with the file or am i which changes did
you make do i understand them
making sure that there's a space to ask
questions about whatever phenomenon it
is that you're looking at so that you
don't make assumptions and
not accurately capture the complex
problem that you're working on
i don't know if that's helpful at all
that that's fantastic you know i mean in
some of what you're touching on there it
kind of was getting to one of my next
questions was
a lot of us when we start off in science
so we have those
kind of heady days of being a post
doctoral researcher and we're really
like our nose is just like up in
against the computer screen we're doing
all sorts of really cool data analytics
and we become assistant professors or
more senior professors for some of us
and
we we stopped really doing that kind of
intense scientific investigation and
we've become kind of the
you know the managers the middle
management ceo of the the van horn
enterprise for example and
you're trying to make sure that
people are supported that they have the
resources they need and that their uh if
there's any
challenges that they're overcome and
that it becomes the dominant thing in
one's
life and i think you're absolutely right
when you said that we didn't train to do
that stuff
no no and actually jack when i have
individuals and some of which you know
we know fairly closely in common
they will come at that point in their
career and say
i'm buried in
admin
and i think i could find ways to become
more efficient at it because
why i
am in this career is to answer big
questions and if i look at my average
work week i'm barely getting to them
and even in that space when we think
about what leadership is in a scientific
team it's too it's to see not with our
eyes but to have vision into the next
scientific
um
area of inquiry
right to be the next the first ants at
the next big space to do important work
and one cost to me when i hear senior
people like yourself saying that is
where is your play at so that you can
take your lab into new spaces they never
could have thought possible but because
you saw it first the lab was in a great
position to be doing whether it's visual
ai or
you know i don't i don't really know
what the next
you know big corner might be
but
um we're sort of like reading and
exploring just stops
as a cost of so much administrative work
in certain areas of team science there
might be some bottlenecks they could be
bottlenecks of communication it could be
bottlenecks of just kind of the cold
start problem or what have you um do you
see like data science playing a role in
helping to kind of like push through
some of those more
expeditiously
uh
i do and that i think like i was just
listening to a talk on uh health health
equity health inequities and big data
and i think if there's there's some real
opportunities in highlighting
again kind of like that
um where should the where would work be
most fruitful next and i do think that
they're patterns and areas that machine
learning can really be important in that
area
in terms of bottlenecks i mean i can't i
can't say unfortunately i feel like
sometimes it might be in assuming others
on your team have coded a particular way
that there's no mistakes in the way in
the language they're using
and moving forward only to go oh no
two weeks ago there was something done
that shouldn't have been done
and having again the ethics and the
the sense of value to be like we have to
stop and go back
we've got to fix it and make it right
when the pressure to get things done and
to manipulate data because who's really
going to know how to check it or fix it
i mean i i saw a lot of my graduate
students really struggle with the sort
of phishing or
manipulation of big data because it is
sometimes so easy to do
but the bottleneck will be who's willing
to say hey we've gotta we've gotta do
this right let's go back a couple weeks
let's fix this and then move forward
um
any reactions to that answer jack well i
was going to say that you touched on
something about students and the role
where students can you know today
as which is completely different than
how it might have been 20 years ago is
that team science is almost baked into
the type of work that we do
how can we make sure that students are
being further trained and educated about
the best ways to be
uh to leverage team science in an
ethical way um and how can we do that
better so that when you get to a
situation like the one you describe it's
just yep that's exactly what we do we go
back and we unspool the problems that
we've created and we find that that
trouble point and then fix it and move
forward again how do we do that best
yeah that's where that's where when i
say leadership is very much about um
walking the walk
and
in in recognizing that for many you were
like they're the first parent right when
they work for you in the lab and they're
watching and they're saying how
does my advisor this assistant professor
that's so smart so bright how do they
handle
and they see all the various events and
that becomes their code of conduct their
way of working
and it's i think it's a personal
a personal
promise and commitment to say i'm going
to run my data science lab in a way
that's upright here's our standards for
you know how we manage data when we say
i've got to raise my
hand and say stop the presses we need to
check this check that like it's in your
behavior that you're that the this
generation and the subsequent
generations of data scientists will
learn how to do work
transparently fairly and ethically
absolutely and thank you marisa salazar
campo from the university of california
irvine for sharing your thoughts with us
today this was a wonderful discussion
thank you i really appreciate it thank
you everyone
you too bye everyone see